[Applause]
you have leveled a small town
you can't handle this alone that's why
I'm bringing it smile
everybody is Charlie a lot of you
requested I do a video for Wolverine vs
Hulk movie news the other day there's a
report that they're actually working on
a movie right now at Marvel with a new
version of Wolverine and obviously a
slightly different version of the Hulk
so we'll break it all down there's a new
round of the giveaway for the Disney
Plus streaming service all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and fan
cast the next version of Wolverine in
the comments which actor do you want to
take over that role from Hugh Jackman so
if you haven't seen the news it was
reported in the past week that Marvel is
developing a new version of Wolverine
vs. Hulk and that would sort of be their
next Thor Ragnarok style movie because
Universal still has the rights to
release the film's Disney can't release
their own Hulk film and I think as part
of that they also can't put Hulk in the
title of a movie so whatever this
Wolverine vs. Hulk movie would be they'd
have to bill it as a new Wolverine movie
with Hulk in it but if you're not a big
comic book reader
one of the huge Easter eggs in putting
Wolverine versus Hulk in a movie is that
Wolverine actually debuted as a
character in Marvel Comics for the first
time in Incredible Hulk number 180 back
in 1974 he literally got his start in
the comics fighting Hulk in a comic book
so Wolverine vs Hulk is the thing that
goes way way back to the 1970s they've
had five or six major fights that'll
break down in this usually the most
famous one you hear people quoting all
the time is the old man Logan
Wolverine versus Hulk fight but of
course as part of this they would have
to recast the Wolverine character but it
would still be the Mark Ruffalo version
of the Hulk he still has movies on his
contract and because of the way they do
motion capture for the hook it's a lot
easier for him to perform the character
as the Hulk even as he gets older it's
not like a Hugh Jackman Wolverine
situation where it gets harder and
harder as he gets older to maintain that
crazy Wolverine body when he runs around
shirtless that doesn't mean the Hugh
Jackman will never come back as the
Wolverine character inside the Marvel
movies I'll talk about that at the end
of the video too but as part of this
news there was also a report that they
might be doing a version of Alpha Flight
because that's part of Wolverines
original back story in the comics and
they would do a version of immortal Hulk
during the movie which is basically God
level strength Hulk or devil level Hulk
technically is more like a dev
than 'god they've already done an
animated version of wolverine versus
hulk it's actually called Hulk vs.
Wolverine but it's based on an Ultimate
Comics storyline that I'll break down in
a second but going back to the beginning
of their comic book fight history
starting with number six the first time
they ever fought was during the end of
Incredible Hulk number 180 the very
first appearance of Wolverine in the
comics that was 1974 The Hulk is
crashing his way through upstate New
York across the Canadian border a very
shadowy Canadian version of General Ross
declares release Weapon X and that's
Canada's military answer to dealing with
the Hulk so this is still Wolverine
before he joined the x-men team but he
does debut in that yellow costume number
5 the next time they fought was when
Wolverine got his first solo comic book
series in 1988 there was a crossover
that year during Incredible Hulk number
340 and of course there was still bad
blood between them left over from their
previous fight in 1974 round 2 was a bit
of a bummer because there was a
character named clay Quartermaine that
came in and stopped them before they
actually were able to rip each other
apart for the next big rematch was in
1999 during Incredible Hulk vol 2 number
8 but it was after a storyline in the
x-men comics where magneto had used his
powers to completely rip Wolverines
adamantium skeleton out of his body so
when this version of Wolverine is
fighting the Hulk he was using the bone
claws and because Hulk's body is so
impervious to damage you can guess what
happened Wolverine
snaps his claws when he tries to claws
Holt's face out 3 is world breaker Hulk
vs. Wolverine during World War Hulk one
of their most famous fights also one of
their shortest but still really badass
the way it went down Hulk has come back
to earth from Sekar for revenge against
the Illuminati when he incorrectly
believes that they're responsible for
the death of his new wife and child back
on Sekar the whole idea with the Planet
Hulk storyline was that they fired him
into outer space to begin with because
they couldn't find a better solution to
deal with the problem of the Hulk he
crash-lands on Sicard dominates and
eventually falls in love with a woman
just when everything seems amazing the
jet that shot him into space explodes
killing his wife and seemingly killing
his unborn child he comes back to earth
to get his revenge against the
Illuminati with his warbound later finds
out that it was actually
one of the members of the warbound that
betrayed him and sabotage the jet in the
first place
but when he lands on earth and gets
ready to start smashing everything one
of the very first fights is Wolverine
they use it as a way to show you how
much more powerful he's gotten because
he's gotten so much matter it's the
maddest most powerful version of the
Hulk that we've seen that's why they
call him world breaker Hulk so they
throw Wolverine at him and you're like
oh [ __ ] oh it's on now Wolverine at the
time had been in his most unbeatable
form they'd had a long history of comic
book bytes trading back and forth so you
assumed that Wolverine is gonna be able
to stop him but with all the heroes
standing around in broad daylight
watching when Wolverine goes to stop him
Hulk almost bitchslaps him into defeat
in moments by dashing his adamantium
skull so many times that it turns his
brains to mush effectively neutralizing
Wolverine the world breaker Hulk version
of Hulk still had a lot of banners mind
so using banners intelligence he knew
that if he attacked Wolverines brain the
center of his mutant abilities to
regenerate it would take him even longer
to heal the damage so it was the
quickest way possible to take Wolverine
out for the entire fight the whole thing
lasted for like two seconds but it's
still one of their most iconic fights to
the next Big Bite was in the Ultimate
Comics with the ultimate Hulk versus
ultimate Wolverine this was the story
line that they based that animated movie
on if you haven't seen it it's called
Hulk vs. Wolverine it was a
direct-to-dvd movie so it's a little
more hardcore than your typical Marvel
animated movie but the comic book story
that it's based on picks up with
Wolverine waking up after a fight with
the Hulk realizing that he's only got
half of his body in his legs had been
ripped off thrown across a mountain so
as half a body Wolverine starts climbing
his way to his legs with just his hands
in his claws he starts remembering the
sequence of events that led to this
fight Nick Fury had called in Wolverine
to recapture and take down Ultimate Hulk
after a series of incidents with the
hook were reported across Europe and
Asia they had tried in a last-ditch
attempt to kill the Hulk by tying a
bunch of bombs to him and throwing him
in the ocean as you would expect he
turns into the Hulk and then swims his
way to Europe and then eventually makes
his way to the Dali Lama to try and
become more Zen to learn why it is the
Hulk's out so much the movie version
they did of this was vastly simplified
it was more
simple Hulk vs. Wolverine fight the
ultimate comic book storyline gets way
more crazy
it has Betty Ross turning into a version
of she-hulk I'll talk about that in a
second too because we have the she-hulk
TV series coming but number one old man
Logan probably their most epic iconic
fight when everybody talks about Hulk
vs. Wolverine this is usually what
they're referencing the darkest timeline
post-apocalyptic future version of
Wolverine versus a darkest timeline
version of Hulk that's been twisted evil
with old age super villains have taken
over the earth and divided it up into
different territories between them after
Mysterio causes Wolverine to hallucinate
an attack on the x-mansion he kills all
the attackers but then spider-man far
from home style he discovers it was all
an illusion in the people that he had
just killed were actually his fellow
x-men the version of the Hulk during
this storyline is not the maestro that's
a slightly different evil future version
of the Hulk the territory he's rolling
over is called Hulk land he winds up
eating Wolverine during their fight
who's healing factor then kicks in while
he's gestating inside Hulk's stomach
then claws his way out from the inside
is their most hardcore iconic bite of
all time in one of the only times that
Wolverine has ever been able to beat
Hulk in a fight the Logan movie only
adapted some of these story elements -
the Hulk stuff but in the movie version
it was Professor X who accidentally
kills the other x-men when he has a
psychic episode causing him to lose
control of his powers if they do wind up
making a Hulk vs. Wolverine movie though
the earliest it could happen if you look
at the phase 4 schedule here would
probably be after the she-hulk series
and per the phase 4 schedule it looks
like it's going to be released sometime
between summer and fall of 2022 after
the moon night series so that's like
tail end Marvel phase 4 right when
they're getting ready to reintroduce or
introduce Fantastic Four and more
mainstream Fox x-men characters into the
universe so it is totally possible Kevin
Feige said all the TV show storylines
would cross over with the movies and set
up those stories so it's possible that
they could use the she-hulk series to
set up another major Hulk movie although
like I said they can't do Sola Houk
movies or put Hulk in the title of a
movie so they really did a Wolverine vs.
Hulk movie they would have to call it
Wolverine subtitle something else as
long as they don't call it Wolverine
Origins I think they'll be fine
I don't know if I believe the rumor
about them doing immortal Hulk during
the next big Hulk movie appearance
because that's more of a devilish
version of the Hulk and he's God level
powerful and if they really want to do a
more hardcore version of the Hulk they
would probably keep that on the Avengers
spin-off TV series the movie versions of
the Hulk that we've seen in the MCU so
far seem to be a little more
family-friendly as for recasting The
Wolverine that's probably the bigger
news like it wouldn't be Hugh Jackman
coming back there are so many people
that are going to audition for this next
version of Wolverine you can't imagine
anyone that's gonna do a better job than
Hugh Jackman so it's gonna be nearly
impossible to find the perfect actor but
think about it realistically I think the
chance of a Wolverine vs. Hulk movie is
very low I think it's more likely that
we'll just see them fight in another
Avengers movie like Avengers 6 or
Avengers secret Wars or some other
larger Avengers x-men crossover movie
but everybody push your Wolverine Marvel
theories in the comments below
what do you think they're gonna do with
the next version of the character and I
am working on a new Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness Scarlet Witch
video that should post the next couple
of days congratulations Peter Turner
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my breakdown
of that leaked Avengers what-if trailer
footage and click here for my breakdown
of that secret birds-of-prey trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]